kann europa krise ja sagt die
kommissionspräsidentin und hat auch
einige ideen energiepreise fachkräfte
europa konvent vorgetragen in ihrer
dritten rede zur lage der union zwischen
krieg und rezession wie kommt europa
durch die krise kommen
phoenix runde
wir haben die innere stärke europas
wieder an die oberfläche gebracht und
wir werden diese ganze stärke auch
benötigen denn die zeit wie die wir für
uns lesung werde nicht einfach sein das
gilt für die familien die im geld
zurechtkommen müssen das gilt für
unternehmen die schwierige
entscheidungen treffen müssen und das
muss ich so sagen hier steht wirklich
viel auf dem spiel
also da von der leyen war das heute
vormittag im europaparlament in
straßburg und damit willkommen meine
damen und herren zur phoenix runde ich
darf ihnen unsere gäste vorstellen an
diesem abend wir begrüßen ganz herzlich
zugeschaltet aus brüssel eric bonse er
beobachtet seit über 20 jahren die
geschicke europas und seit 2004 ist er
als eu korrespondent unterwegs für
unterschiedliche medien willkommen herr
bonse wir begrüßen weiterhin säle sie
ist politikwissenschaftlerin und seit
2008 zehn präsidentin der europäischen
bewegung deutschland willkommen zu
meiner linken alexander marguier erst
volkswirtschaftler von hause aus und sei
2016 chefredakteur des magazins cicero
und herzlich willkommen an veronika
priesmeier
politikwissenschaftlerin und
stellvertretende direktorin europäische
akademie berlin ich arbeite noch daran
willkommen ihnen allen meine damen und
herren politik muss viel leisten in
diesen tagen und die erste einschätzung
kommt von eric bonse aus brüssel herr
bonse idealerweise liefern politiker
antworten in der krise heute also die
rede von ursula von der leyen zur lage
der union ihre dritte was haben sie an
substanz entdeckt
ja da war schon einiges an substanz zu
sehen und zu hören
frau von der leyen hat zum einen
die lage in der ukraine
betont und den versuch russlands die
europäische union zu spalten und
hatte mit vielen symbolen unterstrichen
dass dieses unterfangen natürlich
vereitelt werden also sie hat die
first lady aus kiew eingeladen sie war
in gelb und dem blau gekleidet sie wird
heute abend noch nach kiew reisen und
mit präsident des elends geht dann über
den bitten markt sprechen das ist also
für die ukraine relativ wichtig und auch
konkret allerdings hat sie keine neuen
sanktionen angekündigt keine neuen
button liefern und auch keine
perspektive für den krieg konkreter
wurde es dann bei der energie krise da
hat sie tatsächlich einige maßnahmen
angekündigt die aber wahrscheinlich weit
hinter den erwartungen dann doch
zurückfallen werden das bleibt
abzuwarten da das letzte wort können
doch die 27 eu-staaten haben okay da
werden wir uns auch gleich später noch
etwas genauer darüber beugen vielen dank
erstmal für dieses andre herr börse
gehen wir gleich weiter in der runde zu
denen zähle also es ist schon
angesprochen worden optisch und
inhaltlich hat frau von der leyen heute
dieser solidarität mit der ukraine
betont und in den mittelpunkt gerückt
aber die frage ist natürlich weil
menschen unterschiedlich auf so etwas
schauen reicht das inmitten der krise
also ich würde eric bonse absolut recht
geben ursula von der leyen kann sehr gut
machtvolle symbole schaffen und ich
glaube das ist mir heute gelungen dass
sie diese solidarität mit der ukraine
ganz zentral in ihrer rede verankert hat
nicht nur in den farben aber auch dass
die first lady solon scada aber ich
glaube dass das sie jetzt nach kiew
heißt dass das war sehr kraftvoll aber
klar muss auch sein dass natürlich die
eu nicht nur ein loblied auf die ukraine
ist und dass da natürlich auch noch ein
bisschen mehr kommen muss und sie hat
einige sehr konkrete dinge vorgestellt
in ihrer rede was mir ein bisschen
gefehlt hat war das größere bild sie hat
kein größeres bild gemalt und das
erwarte ich mir ein stück weit von
seiner state of the union rede dass man
ein ziel oder ein bild gemalt wo man hin
möchte und da war sie fand ich nicht
sehr einheitlich und viele pinselstriche
haben mir auch gefehlt oder waren zu
dünn
wenn man in dem bild bleibt also beim
thema rechtsstaatlichkeit wie es
insgesamt mit institutionellen reformen
weiter gehen soll aber wie gesagt
machtvolle symbole gegenüber der ukraine
und das ist natürlich momentan auch sehr
im zentrum hier über die pinselstriche
insbesondere die ihm gefehlt haben reden
wir im laufe der sendung auch noch ein
bisschen genauer aber wenn es darum geht
herr marquis so etwas wie ein gesamtbild
zu zeichnen wir waren jetzt nicht von
visionen sprechen aber doch immerhin ein
schönes gesamtbild
dann war eine auch der ausführung zu
sagen russland führt nicht nur krieg
gegen die ukraine sondern auch krieg
gegen die europäische wirtschaft gegen
die europäische energieversorgung und
dann muss man natürlich an der stelle
fragen die überzeugend sind die
antworten die wir bisher hören konnten
von der eu-kommission und ihrer
präsidentin also vielleicht erst noch
mal ganz generell zu die rede von ursula
von der leyen weil es war ja eine rede
zum zustand der union und da muss ich
sagen waren doch wesentliche punkte von
überhaupt nicht statt also ein thema das
ja nun wirklich jeden umtreibt jeden eu
bürger oder überhaupt jedem europäischen
bürger ist das thema inflation die
inflation hat sie einmal erwähnt ganz am
rande kam nicht vor das war nicht ihr
thema fand ich also enttäuschend
und
wenn man ihr zugehört hat also sie hat
gesprochen wie wie ursula von der leyen
pflegt zu reden mit vielen gesten mit
viel pathos
es wird auf mich relativ einstudiert
aber aber das ist das ist ja
das ist ja in ordnung man hatte den
eindruck also eigentlich müssen wir uns
freuen die krise ist da und das ist für
uns eine chance dass jetzt alles besser
wird so hat wie er versucht
transportieren ich sehe das ein bisschen
anders und es ist ja auch keineswegs so
wie frau von der leyen das geschildert
hat das also die eu jetzt angesichts der
bedrohung aus russland gemeint ist es
ist ja nicht so dass alle gleichermaßen
hinter den sanktionen stehen gegen gegen
russland nicht alle sind einer meinung
was die militärische unterstützung der
ukraine betrifft insofern glaube ich war
der zustand der union den sie versucht
hat darzulegen doch doch sehr doch sehr
geschönt und was ihre zweite frage
angeht oder überhaupt die erste frage
wie wie kann wie kann die europäische
union antworten auf diese auf diese
wirtschaftliche und geopolitische krise
es wird schwierig es wird sehr schwierig
weil es und sind ja im wesentlichen die
hände gebunden das muss man einfach
sagen also die energie krise ist da und
die werden wir nicht einfach von heute
auf morgen lösen können was da für
momente sein könnten wären wir
wahrscheinlich gleich noch kommen wir
natürlich in der sendung aber vielen
dank für den einstieg also das bild hat
lücken was ursache von der leyen
gezeichnet hat und es ist manchmal ein
wenig rosa geraten so fasst ich herrn x
gehe jetzt zusammen und frau priesmeier
ich versuche jetzt auf diese weise
entschuldigung
da war auch noch ein anderes moment drin
da war noch mal die frage drin auch das
ist ein krieg gegen unsere werte das
hatte sie auch betont und hat gesagt es
geht am ende des tages um autokratie
gegen demokratie und wir wollen diesen
kampf gewinnen die frage ist nur
angesichts auch dieser kleinen
rechtsstaatlichen momente die wir auch
finden in ländern wie ungarn und polen
wie einig ist die europäische union
eigentlich in diesem punkt
die hat das ist natürlich eine sehr gute
frage also wenn man sagen wie man sich
anschaut wer insgesamt die zurzeit in
der europäischen union ist das thema
natürlich wäre es spielt eine sehr große
rolle rechtsstaatlichkeit thema
demokratie thema korruption wir wissen
dass wir da in der eu-27 nicht immer uns
einig sind das haben wir ja schon vor
ihn angesprochen es geht ja um aber es
geht ja auch natürlich um auch im
entwicklungen in polen aber auch
tatsächlich um
antidemokratische tendenzen in anderen
europäischen staaten sowohl im osten als
auch im westen
und deswegen ist es tatsächlich so ein
bisschen enttäuschend dass dieses thema
demokratie also verteidigung unsere
demokratische werte und verteidigung
auch erst dran bleiben an dem was uns
wirklich mal zusammenbindet soweit in
der rede platz gefunden hat wir haben am
anfang erstmal gesprochen wir klar
ukraine spielte der sehr große rolle da
natürlich das thema energie und
wirtschaft dann gab es das ganze und
große also die globale perspektive auch
natürlich das einsetzen der normative
werte transfer nach afrika asien und und
und und dann irgendwann zum schluss
sprechen wir natürlich auch über das
thema werte im inneren da hätte ich mir
tatsächlich mal auch eine andere
schwerpunkt verschiebung gewünscht weil
ich kann es verstehen dass wir in zeiten
des krieges in dem wir sie auf jeden
fall jetzt gerade befinden dass wir uns
eher auf das zusammenhalten darauf dass
speisen konzentrieren wie sollen
doch alle länder mitnehmen und dafür
gewinnen dass wir zusammenhalten weil
die zeiten werden hat sein da gebe ich
ihnen recht inflation spielt eine
ernorme oder auch in polen aber wir
dürfen diese grundprinzipien nicht außer
acht lassen das ist extrem wichtig dass
wir wissen dass wir nach wie vor auf
probleme den eigenen in eigenen gespielt
hätte da auf einem hof haben und die
müssen wir natürlich auch entscheidend
lösen und das war ihnen quantitativ
etwas zu schlank gehalten wenn ich war
ein bisschen zu spät also ich denke mal
von der schwerpunktsetzung hätte ich mir
dass es ein bisschen anders gewünscht
aber ansonsten natürlich der letzte
punkt das ist natürlich wichtig dass man
sagt ja es ist ein spiel gegen
demokratie versus autoritarismus
es ist ja auch schön dass wir das
endlich entdeckt haben wenn wir die rede
von der leyen vom letzten jahr hören
dann finden wir dieses thema fast gar
nicht also wir haben uns im letzten
jahrhundert leyen hat sich im letzten
jahr sehr stark natürlich auf die
pandemie bekämpfung konzentriert auf
next generation programm auf das thema
jugendschutz war auch niemals uns
natürlich die ukraine spielte da gar
keine rolle autoritarismus der
information propaganda spielte
eigentlich gar keine rolle man hätte
sich eigentlich vorstellen können dass
zwischen west balkan und china da klafft
eine große lücke die welt findet keine
beachtung also umso schöner also sehr
gut dass die ukraine jetzt so einen
großen schwerpunkt genommen hat aber es
ist die frage ob sie ist das jetzt ein
moment um oder ist es wirklich eine
zeitenwende und zwar auf europäischer
ebene da würden wir jetzt ein bisschen
tiefer einsteigen in die vielen dank für
ihre anträge
in diese ukraine problematik franz eller
sie hatten ja sozusagen schon ein
bisschen auch angemerkt also das
optische momentum und die art und weise
wie bestimmte dinge nach vorn gerückt
werden
formuliert hat frau von der leyen heute
putin wird scheitern und die ukraine und
europa werden sich durchsetzen
wörtliches zitat
das ist natürlich am ende des tages und
wir haben auch diese woche hier in der
phoenix runde schon diskutiert über die
frage wann ist ein krieg gewonnen also
das wording spielt eine ganz große rolle
wann hat sich europa gegen russland
durchgesetzt weiß man dass
also kurze antwort wenn die ukraine
wieder ihre volle territoriale
souveränität hat und zwar die in den
grenzen von 2014 also ich nehme da auch
explizit grimm mit rein das war ja
letztlich der erste
eigentlich die erste zeitenwende für die
ukraine die wir damals vor allem in
deutschland nicht haben wahr haben
wollen so wirklich wir nicht darauf
reagiert haben nicht angemessen aus
heutiger perspektive
wohingegen auch unsere mittel und
osteuropäischen partner immer gesagt
haben wir müssen viel stärker auftreten
gegen russland da haben wir auch als als
deutschland viel
lehrgeld jetzt auch zahlen müssen
insofern glaube ich dass das der punkt
ist wenn man sich durchgesetzt hat aber
ich glaube dieser weg dahin ist
natürlich sehr schwierig wir können
gerade schwer definieren wann dieser
zeitpunkt erreicht werden wird mit
welchem mitteleinsatz und umso wichtiger
ich glaube sozusagen dieses thema der
der einigkeit der europäischen union ist
ja schon noch da und darum ist es schon
relevant und auch wichtig dass frau von
der leyen da heute drauf eingegangen ist
also ich würde jetzt auch nicht dass so
beschreiben dass wir da jetzt
sozusagen nicht mehr an einem strang
ziehen aber der druck wird natürlich
stärker und die interessen sind
natürlich da das ist so das ist haben
wir auf föderaler ebene in deutschland
wenn es ums geld wenn es um den einfluss
geht und das haben wir genauso in der
europäischen union bislang sind wir
immer zu einer entscheidung gekommen und
das ist letztlich dann auch der
demokratische prozess ja sie haben genau
den neuralgischen punkt jetzt
angesprochen dann wenn es ans geld geht
es bringt uns auch gleich noch mal zu
hören
dass frau von der leyen heute auch noch
mal aufgelistet hatte in ihrer rede
waren noch mal das was an summen
geflossen ist also da war vom team
europa die rede was finanzhilfen im wert
von über 19 milliarden euro freigemacht
hat wenn man die und das ist ohne
militärhilfe gerechnet da kommen wir
glaube ich auf zweieinhalb milliarden
euro da ist eine menge geld im spiel
aber es ist natürlich es tut jedem
einzelnen mitgliedstaat auch ein
bisschen weh was da gemacht wird das
sind ordentliche summen es ist ein
zweistelliger milliardenbetrag die frage
ist ist das das solidarische moment was
sie heute angesprochen wird oder müssen
wir noch mehr tun ich weiß nicht dass
sie damit gemeint hat das solidarische
moment ist glaube ich jetzt mal dass wir
uns als bevölkerung und solidarisch
fühlen mit der ukraine das ist ja erst
mal gut und richtig dass wir einige
flüchtlinge aufnehmen dass wir die
kleinen unterstützen militärisch
dass wir die ukraine finanziell
unterstützen aber kommen wir doch mal
auf einem punkt hilft deutlich deutlich
strittiger ist also kaum hatte frau von
der leyen ihre rede beendet meldet sich
die staatskanzlei in ungarn zu wort und
sagt also so wie sie das gefühl der
titel mit denen mit den sanktionen das
ist ja überhaupt nicht der fall nicht
also frau von der leyen hat ja sogar
gesagt die sanktionen treffen russland
so hart dass man da mittlerweile auf
kühlschränken mikrochips aufbaut um sie
in banse einzubauen also viel sagen die
sanktionen funktionieren sie hatte die
rede kaum beendet da sagt ich weiß nicht
was ich glaube der chef der
staatskanzlei im budapester nein das
stimmt also alles überhaupt nicht ja die
sanktionen funktioniert überhaupt nicht
wir schießen uns praktisch jeden tag
permanent in den fuß und so kann das
nicht weitergehen also das muss einem
klar sein da kommt noch was und die
kältere winter wird desto mehr wird
diese diskussion aufflammen und desto
aggressiver und kontroverser wird sie
geführt werden also
das gebe ich nur zu bedingt und das ist
ein ganz wichtiger punkt dass diese
absetzbewegung die sie da sozusagen
jetzt auf der rhetorischen ebene
beschreiben eric bonse wird uns mit
sicherheit mit seinem brüsseler blick
und seine erfahrung noch einmal sagen
können also wir haben diese sieben
sanktionspaket das hat man alleine heute
auch nochmal mit stolz festgestellt die
ja auch teilweise mit sehr viel kraft
und nerven auch nur und zeitdauer
entstanden sind und die sanktionen
würden von dauer sein aber das
angesprochene ungarn es heißt oder hieß
schon letzte woche dass diplomaten da
mehr oder weniger ich formuliere es mal
jetzt so in veto stimmung sind was hat
viktor orban vor was hören sie jetzt
müssen wir versuchen ihre mikro noch mal
auf zu kriegen herr bonse
möglicherweise sind sie stumm geschaltet
[Musik]
okay er bauen sie dann versuchen wir sie
gleich noch mal akustisch reinzuholen
und versuchen das jetzt noch einmal wo
wir über ungarn gesprochen haben mit
frau priesmeier sie haben mir
freundlicherweise gestattet sozusagen
mit teil 1 zu arbeiten bedanke mich
also bevor wir noch mal auf diese
installationspakete zurückkommen gehen
wir in eine punkt rein der da auch mit
schwingt bei der großen ukraine
problematik wenn ich erstmal so fassen
darf in der beschreibung oder in der
wahrnehmung von vielen findet sich die
ukraine in gewisser weise auf der
überholspur wir wissen genau worauf ich
an spiele es gab beiden es gibt ein
ministerpräsident mit dem schneefall der
erst kürzlich sowohl in berlin als auch
in brüssel vorstellig geworden ist und
gesagt hat jungs das ist schön dass wir
jetzt den kandidatenstatus haben seit
märz aber wie wäre es wenn wir zum ende
des jahres sind auch mit verhandlungen
beginnen also es würde das gut gefallen
vielleicht schon in zwei jahren im klub
zu sein was ist realistisch zeit für
eine ausführliche antwort na ja okay
also ich glaube die perspektive von zwei
jahren ist nicht wirklich realistisch
ist ist es ist natürlich ein teil der
symbolpolitik
beim thema verhandlungen
und da würde ich auch wirklich mal keine
wette abschließen und man sagt okay was
ist dann die nächste studie die lange es
dauert wir müssen daran denken es gibt
verhandlungen dann müsste es akzeptiert
werden und zwar nicht nur von der eu und
von der von der ukraine oder grün
jeweiligen beitrittsland sondern auch
von anderen mitgliedsstaaten und dann
gibt es immer noch kontroversen und so
weiter und so fort es ist ein langer
prozess aber
wo sie absolut recht haben ist dass die
ukraine es ist zwar beitrittskandidaten
statue beitrittskandidaten land geworden
aber bereits seit der revolution der
würde oder kurz danach ist ja auch nun
vertieft das freihandelsabkommen und
natürlich aber assoziierungsabkommen mit
der europäischen der unterschrieben
worden und das darf man nicht
unterschätzen weil das ist ja eben das
ist ein bisschen wechsel von den
typischen nachbarschaftspolitik also
sowie machen irgendetwas miteinander
aber so richtig wissen wir nicht wohin
die reise geht hin zu einer politik die
sagt okay wie integrieren und
wirtschaftlich aber auch natürlich
politisch und in anderen bereichen immer
enger oder immer ein grauer die kammer
anders zusammen und das hat tatsächlich
die ersten früchte getragen vor dem
aufguss ist krieges und deshalb das hat
auch geholfen
in den ersten tagen des krieges der eine
oder andere maßnahme zu machen beispiel
die geflüchteten sie könnten natürlich
so schnell in die europäische union
einreisen weil es ja bereits dieses
frieden dieser freie
regime gab das heißt sie waren nicht
mehr lang jemals ganz entfernte
drittstaaten angehörigen sondern sie
könnten ganz normal in die und das
territorium der europäischen union
anreisen und daraufhin hat man natürlich
auch die möglichkeit gegeben in so einer
kriegssituation bestimmte erleichterung
auch für die gefürchteten zu zu erlassen
oder auch das was jetzt das was ursula
von der leyen angesprochen hat ist das
anschluss an den strommarkt dass man
sehr schnell wirklich mal die
stromtrassen da nach vorne gebracht hat
und das alles möglich gemacht hat das
heißt ja das stimmt ukraine ist bereits
vor dem krieg etwas stärker mit der
europäischen union integriert worden das
hilft natürlich enorm aber das was noch
mehr hilft ist diese enorme
unterstützung und zwar auf allen ebenen
europäische union deutschland oder auch
natürlich die einzelnen mitgliedstaaten
hin zur europäisierung der ukraine so
könnte man das nennen und zwar seit 2014
oder sogar davor aber auf jeden fall sei
2014 weil seit diesem zeitpunkt sind
wirklich die kräfte administration also
administrative kräfte politik auch
natürlich verwaltung sehr sehr stark
darauf vorbereitet worden das ist
irgendwann diese engere beziehungen
geben wird und wir haben inzwischen in
dem land sowohl in der verwaltung als
auch natürlich im wirtschaftlichen
sektor also auch in
zivilgesellschaftlichen sektor und so
weiter sehr sehr starke player die sich
wirklich sehr in richtung westen gucken
und möglicherweise auch und das ist ja
das typische bei den beitrittsländern an
eine oder andere stelle ein kleines
bisschen weiter sind denn die
erweiterung es ist nicht so verläuft
nicht so dass die länder werden
irgendwann so wie wir das kennen wir ja
auch zum beispiel von den baltischen
staaten sondern dass ihnen ganz anderen
integrations weg an nehmen sie müssen
natürlich die gesetzgebung annehmen aber
auf der anderen seite sie finden sich
ihren eigenen weg wo sie die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung auch
natürlich politische stabilisierung ein
oder zwei schritte nach vorne bringen ja
ein gewisser weg ist noch zu machen bei
der korruption natürlich in abrede das
dürfen wir nicht verschweigen und
sondergleichen ist diese
europabegeisterung richtig da mit dem
was wir erlebt haben bevor ich gleich
einen zweiten anlauf machen fehlen dann
vor priesmeier
mitteln bonse gehört in dieses thema
noch rein und frau holle ich weiß dass
ihnen das auch am herzen liegt es gab
ein paar merkwürdige momente bereits im
frühjahr als der kandidatenstatus
vergeben wurde auf einem eu-gipfel weil
am vormittag quasi zum frühstück zu
einem kalten frühstück wurden die
regierungschefs des westbalkan gebeten
um zu sagen schön dass ihr da wart die
sind zum teil seit 20 jahren in der
warteschleife was macht das für das
innerbetriebliche klima
also schön schön dass dass sie da waren
aber ich glaube dass
man sollte das nicht so als gegensatz
verstehen dass die westbalkanstaaten
unterstützen ja vielleicht serbien
einmal ein bisschen in klammern gestellt
aber in ganz überwiegend unterstützen
sie die ukraine unterstützen die
sanktionspolitik und stehen da sozusagen
gemeinsam mit der europäischen union
und ich glaube darum muss man das auch
zusammen denken also dass wir nicht eine
erweiterung der ukraine ohne die
westbalkanstaaten
haben können die wie sie richtig sagen
ja schon seit zum teil vielen jahren
warten signifikanter reformen
durchgeführt haben natürlich auch immer
noch schwächen haben an denen man
arbeiten muss aber die
erweiterungspolitik der europäischen
union ist letztlich so ein umfassendes
transformationsprojekte was wir
letztlich in den mittel und
osteuropäischen staaten gesehen haben
auch wenn wir da heute schwächen haben
aber die
schnelligkeit der gesellschaftlichen der
politischen der staatlichen
transformation sucht er wirklich
seinesgleichen und darum glaube ich dass
auch vor dem hintergrund dieser
autoritären tendenzen in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft wir es uns
gar nicht leisten können das ohne den
westbalkan zu denken dass wir letztlich
diese freiheitliche demokratische
grundordnung so eine integrations
landschaft haben die letztlich auch
natürlich die westbalkanstaaten umfassen
muss die ukraine umfassen muss und mal
da umfassen muss natürlich wenn die
kriterien eingehalten werden aber da
muss braucht es letztlich ganz klare
politische signale dass man das will und
dass man dann auch wirklich voran geht
danke frau stelle bevor wir das ukraine
kapitel schließen machen wir nochmal
einen zweiten anlauf bei eric bonse und
noch mal groß nach brüssel und ich sehe
sie hören mich weiterhin gut wir waren
bei diesen sanktions paketen auf die
frau von der leyen stolz war kurz stehen
geblieben die sanktion sondern auch von
dauer sein aber es ist die frage was
macht eigentlich viktor orban seine
diplomaten offenbar ein bisschen in veto
stimmung was hören sie in brüssel
naja viktor orban hat ja versucht die
verlängerung der sanktionen die heute
übrigens anstand zu verhindern er wollte
drei oligarchen kommunistisch streichen
dass es ihm am ende nicht gelungen
insofern muss man sagen war seine
politik dar hat die sackgasse geführt
es hat er hat es aber immerhin geschafft
zum einen gegen den laden zu weiteren
sanktionen auszubrennen sind wir
bekommen jetzt unter lion auch kein
neues sanktionspaket präsentiert was
eigentlich erwartet worden war und er
hat natürlich den finger in die wunde
gelegt und diese wunden blutet schon
sehr stark er hat gesagt diese sanktion
haben nicht die erwünschte wirkung
erzielt sie haben nicht dazu geführt
dass der krieg beendet wird sondern sie
schaden teilweise den europäern mehr als
russland und das ist ja ein punkt der
auch selbst in deutschland viele
menschen bewegt und das habe ich ehrlich
gesagt bei von der leyen vermisst sie
hat keine echte
evaluierung keine lag eine echte
abschätzung der sanktionen gegeben und
jetzt auch keinen ausblick gegeben sie
sagt wir werden diese sanktionen weiter
durchhalten aber wozu eigentlich also
handelt es sich wirklich nur um
strafmaßnahmen oder ist das nicht auch
wie es ergebnis krieges hier in brüssel
gesagt wurde ein diplomatisches tool
also ein werkzeug ein pfund das man
nutzen kann um verhandlungen
einzusteigen und das ist übrigens ein
ganz interessanter punkt wir haben ja
gehört dass bundeskanzler scholz mit
putin telefoniert hat und auch eine
verhandlungslösung anstrebt und davon
dazu von frau von der leyen kein wort
ganz im gegenteil sie hat gesagt keine
blumen kein entgegenkommen da scheinen
wir die ansichten aufeinander zu prallen
und ich finde das bedenklich weil es
fehlt die perspektive wann soll dieser
krieg entropie soll dieser krieg enden
und was ist eigentlich dann das ergebnis
stehen wir dann hinterher wieder in
einem kalten krieg mit
einer eine einer mauer quer durch europa
die dann eben durch am russischen grenze
verläuft das fehlte mir in ihrer eine
rede sehr stark und im übrigen sie hat
also insgesamt
glaube ich 28 mal das stichwort ukraine
genannt aber ist ganz selten auf die
europäischen bürger eingegangen das ist
ein krasses missverhältnis man hat das
gefühl die europäische union dreht sich
nun um karriere und das wird dadurch
bestärkt dass sie heute abend nach tier
gefahren wir bauen so vielen dank für
diesen gedanken weil dann immer direkt
auf und er knüpft ein bisschen an das an
was herr magie auch schon einen super im
grunde genommen auch in großen
rezessions inflationsthema in dem was
sie mehr oder weniger alle ein bisschen
schon haben durchklingen lassen was ihn
alle ein bisschen zu knapp gekommen ist
in dieser rede wenn wir auf den befund
kommen dann würde der erst mal so glaube
ich unstrittig heißen nicht nur
deutschland sondern in europa in gänze
steht im kommenden winter vor einer
rezession
und was vorher kommt nämlich die
inflation das haben wir direkt schon
können wir schon wahrnehmen eben den
prozentzahlen die wir haben da
deutschland zwar über acht
großbritannien geht schon quasi ist
schon weit im zweistelligen bereich und
die frage ist dann wie street band wie
entschlossen agiert eigentlich eine eu
kommission die frage ist ja gar nicht
wird es eine rezession geben sondern
eher wie tief wird sie sein und wie
lange wird sie dauern das ist schon mal
der erste punkt und wenn wir irgend
jetzt über die ukraine so reden als ob
die am ende des jahres mitglied der eu
werden könnte sollte man vielleicht doch
noch zu bedenken geben dass der krieg
noch lange nicht vorbei ist der ist noch
lange nicht vorbei putin wird es sich
nicht erlauben können in irgendwelche
verhandlungslösungen einzulegen die ihm
sozusagen hinter den status quo ante
bringen das wird nicht passieren
die energie krise wird uns weiter
erhalten bleiben das ist völlig klar so
dass das sind das sind probleme die kann
man nicht über nacht lösen irgendwo muss
die energie herkommen wie schwer das ist
das erleben wir jeden tag das erleben
wir an den fahrten des robert habeck in
die golfstaaten und an den ganz
schnellen aufbau von von denen von den
flüssiggas terminals und und das zweite
problem ist in der tat die schuldenkrise
die eben verbunden ist mit der inflation
da können wir gar nicht viel machen das
ist entweder wir bekämpfen die inflation
in dem die leitzinsen erhöht werden
indem die ezb die leitzinsen erhöht wenn
sie das tut geht vielleicht die
inflation runter aber dann haben wir
eine staatsschuldenkrise in ländern wie
italien wo am ende möglicherweise die
staatspleite droht also da sitzen dann
wirklich das ist das ist ein dilemma und
ich sehe nicht
wie die eu-kommission da irgendwie
schnell darauf reagieren kann außer
wieder irgendwelche next generation
force zu zu bilden wo dann geld in
großem stil umverteilt wird aber das
kann ja nicht die lösung der probleme
seien strukturelle probleme die gelöst
werden müssen darum geht es und da habe
ich jetzt auch nicht besonders viele
ansätze von von frau von der leyen
gehört natürlich ist diese bietet das
abschöpfen der über gewinn steuer durch
dieses oder das außer kraft setzen
dieses merit order prinzip das mag schon
das mag schon eine möglichkeit sein aber
die kann natürlich auf dauer überhaupt
nicht tragen das ist eine eine
notmaßnahme und da habe ich jetzt
wirklich nicht erkannt außer irgendwie
was sie gesagt hat ja wir brauchen wir
brauchen arbeitskräfte aus dem ausland
wir müssen uns seltene erden sichern
aber mehr habe ich da jetzt auch nicht
entdecken können das war jetzt nicht
fertig mit was für einer
bestandsaufnahme dessen was sie gehört
haben und frau priesmeier wenn sie
anschließend der bevor der beiden herren
war jetzt im grunde genommen die
menschen europas die bevölkerung für
diese 480 mio ich habe gar nicht
stattgefunden so richtig ne
tatsächlich sind die rede nicht so
richtig also man hat von dem team europa
gesprochen ich habe mich auch gefragt
was das eigentlich ist also da gibt es
einen eindruck wie als europäische
kommission schaffen das nicht
okay das war die präsidentin der
europäischen kommission aber trotzdem
die menschen sind nicht richtig
angekommen und ganz kurz ganz kurze
anmerkung dieses strukturelle problem
von dem wir gesprochen haben das
strukturelle problem heißt das wäre
natürlich immer uns
zum beispiel in puncto energiepolitik
geben nur auf bestimmte länder
konzentriert haben und das ist ja die
rechnung die wir jetzt zahlen also es
ist es war damals wie bei der finanz und
wirtschaftskrise in griechenland haben
wir gemerkt okay wir haben uns zu sehr
auf amerikanische fonds belassen oder
darauf dass die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung weitergeht und so weiter und
so fort das war wirklich eine harte
krise die gezeigt hat okay was ähnlich
nicht richtig funktioniert und jetzt
natürlich der russische angriff ab der
ukraine es ist wirklich auch wieder so
ein moment der sagt okay jetzt machen
wir aber ordnung was unsere
energiequellen angeht was unsere
energiegewinnung angeht diversifizierung
und so weiter und so fort es ist
natürlich bitter es ist hart aber da
müssen wir durch zu den menschen zu der
bevölkerung
ist
das was angesprochen worden es ist
natürlich das thema konferenz zur
zukunft europas
ganz zum schluss noch ganz zum schluss
ganz tatsächlich
im hinblick auf diese dieser reformen
und auch das thema okay die das was ja
dann im rahmen von den lang nicht so
lange aber trotzdem einjährigen prozess
angesprochen worden ist soll jetzt in
eine oder andere form umgesetzt werden
die frage ist okay wie glaubwürdig ist
das
und das was soeben zeigt so ein bisschen
dass das bin ja nicht dass das sehr
nahrhafte darstellung oder die show
hafte rede es ist immer so diesen
menschenschicksale die beide unsere
schlafen also davon hinein angesprochen
worden ist die polnischen helferinnen
die ukrainischen personen und so weiter
und so fort da sind natürlich schöne
beispiele um zu zeigen ok europa ist
durch menschen gebaut aber ergebnis der
oma in marzahn nicht weiter die jäger
als klage frage es wichtig was
interessant ist ist die proklamation
dass das nächste jahr europäische ja
unser thema unter dem thema aus und
weiterbildung können außen weiterbildung
stattfindet weil man merkt okay
vielleicht gesprächen nicht über
citizens aber wir sprechen über
arbeitskräfte die werden wir brauchen
denn natürlich die fachkräftemangel ist
ein großes problem und zwar nicht nur in
deutschland das sehen wir in einen
ländern da sehe ich tatsächlich eine
möglichkeit sich auch das thema eben
professionalisierung weiterbildung und
qualifizierung zu konzentrieren und
vielleicht damit erreichen wir
tatsächlich auch menschen die ja nicht
nur begeisterte europäer im herzen sind
sondern auch diejenigen die einfach in
europa leben oder hier wohnen möchten
arbeiten möchten und ihre familien
gründen möchten das ist interessant aber
schauen wie im nächsten jahr ja das auch
jeden tag ein weiterer ball der in der
luft ist geworfen von ursula von der
leyen in ihrer dritten rede zur lage der
union
und frau solle wenn wir noch mal
sozusagen auf die befindlichkeit auch
von menschen in unterschiedlichen
ländern europas es müssen jetzt nicht
mitgliedstaaten seien schauen und wenn
wir uns den blick dann schweifen lassen
zu großbritannien wo im moment ohnehin
alles ein bisschen aus den fugen ist dem
tod von elizabeth der zweite aber so zb
die notenbank die entscheidung über eine
leitzins an passen auch deswegen vertrag
hat aber da gibt es jetzt proteste und
bewegung die sagen don't pay bezahlen
nicht deine energie und stromrechnung
ist das was was wir eventuell auch
erwarten müssen dass das rüberschwappt
eine blaupause
naja davor ist man glaube ich nicht
gefeit wir sind in einem sehr
dynamischen
system oder in einem sehr dynamischen
phase ich glaube momentan kommt es drauf
an wie kalt wird der winter wie lange
dauert der winter also sind einfach
faktoren mit denen man nur schwer schwer
rechnen kann was ich aber durchaus sehr
interessant finde wenn man sich so die
krisen in der letzten 20 jahre in der
abfolge anschaut und mit der derzeitigen
situation
vergleicht ist dass die europäische
union eine sehr sehr starke
in der sehr starken rolle ist also die
kommission vor allem weil wir haben wenn
wir uns an die staatsschuldenkrise
erinnern da gab es ja im grunde sehr
wenig regeln auf europäischer ebene da
hatten wir die nächtelang gipfel die
staatschefs die nachts um drei dinge
entschieden haben ob jetzt griechenland
in der euro-zone bleiben kann oder nicht
wir haben jetzt geordnete verfahren die
auch bislang sehr effizient
funktionieren das sind demokratische
verfahren wie wir den energiemarkt
strukturieren was für vorschläge wir für
sanktionen machen und ich glaube das
darf man nicht gering schätzen weil wir
in der lage sind darauf mit ordentlicher
gesetzgebung zu reagieren und nicht
diese ad-hoc gipfel zwischen staatliche
entscheidungen treffen müssen und da ist
die kommission in der sehr starken
situation und ich glaube das hat frau
von der leyen heute versucht
klarzumachen
ob sie das jetzt schaffen wird da ist
sie natürlich immer wie in allen
europapolitischen entscheidungen auch
auf die mithilfe der der mitgliedstaaten
angehören sind und letztlich gerade auch
die
frage jetzt der energie armut das sind
natürlich auch nationale fragen die
diskussionen die wir hier in deutschland
haben
mit sozusagen dem energie bonus und also
ich glaube da sind natürlich auch die
mitgliedstaaten gefragt da jetzt
sozusagen jede sozialpolitische maßnahme
auf die europäische union transferieren
zu wollen ist dann glaube ich auch ein
bisschen viel aber erstmal ist es glaube
ich sehr gut dass wir eine reihe von
maßnahmen in der energiepolitik auch in
wirtschaftspolitischen fragen erst mal
in diesem geordneten verfahren haben das
effizient ist das demokratisch ist und
alle relevanten akteure mit einbezieht
vielen dank geordnet und parlamentarisch
ich spreche nur mal eric bonse an könnte
vielleicht auch das werden das sind zwei
weitere bälle die heute in die luft
gekommen sind die auch irgendwie
erwartet wurden am ende war sogar
weniger benannt worden als gesagt aber
es gab eine wirkmächtige zahl
140 milliarden euro sie wird nur auf
viele anspiele auf das ich glaube es
würde es anders in brüssel auf das
abschöpfen von über gewinn also ein
gesetzentwurf der eu-kommission wenn ich
es nicht falsch gelesen habe und am ende
lasst uns den kuchen verteilen die frage
ist wie praktikabel ist das und zweites
stichwort die energie müssen minister
hahn aufgefordert da auch sich um einen
gaspreis deckel zu kümmern was können
wir davon von dieser front vermelden
ja der gaspreis deckel ist vom tisch
kann man sagen das war eine große
überraschung für mich heute
dieser gast deckel war bei den
energieministern am vergangenen freitag
groß und breit diskutiert wird man hat
sich nicht geeinigt und das ist
natürlich ein problem denn wir haben
gesehen der gast weiß es gleich heute
nach der rede von frau von der leyen
wieder in die höhe gestellt um zwölf
prozent das zeigt also die märkte
reagieren auf die rede und diese diese
tendenz die wir hatten zum sinkenden
preisen ist schon wieder vorbei das war
also eine enttäuschung andererseits war
es erfreuliche geschichte dass frau von
der leyen gesagt hat wir müssen die
soziale marktwirtschaft neu definieren
wir müssen sagen die
krisengewinnler müssen auch irgendwo die
da beitrag leisten und dieser soll jetzt
also 140 milliarden euro betragen das
klingt erstmal noch sehr viel geld bei
lichte betrachtet ist es aber gar nicht
so viel da standort alleine für das
dritte entlastungspaket 65 milliarden
euro veranschlagt und für 27 eu-länder
sind natürlich 100 tieren zu 140
milliarden dann letzten endes nur ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein im übrigen
ist gar nicht klar wie dieses geld
eigentlich generiert wie es abgeschöpft
werden soll also große krisengewinner
sind zum beispiel shell in den
niederlanden oder energiekonzerne in
norwegen und so weiter und so fort wie
will man das geld ran und will man ist
an die staaten daran die bürger
umverteilen großes fragezeichen
also da ist noch einiges an feinarbeit
zu leisten das war ja auch durchaus eine
der vielen dank herr börse eine der
kritikpunkte heute dass sie wie sie das
ja häufiger mal tut auch ein bisschen im
ungefähren geblieben ist wenn wir uns
eine mit blick auf die uhr eine ganz
entspannte schlussrunde können sowie das
aufnehmen was ja auch drin war in der
rede und zwar ganz am ende aber das
bewusstsein europa ist wieder ein player
und ist ein auch durch diesen krieg
gefordert sich auch global als akteur
wieder zu beweisen und b europa will
aber sich tatsächlich noch mal ein
bisschen neu aufsetzen durch ein
europäisches konvent wo dann und das
parlament hat es im juni vorgeschlagen
dinge wie institutioneller aufbau die
frage von abschaffung von einstimmigkeit
im rat wichtig in außenpolitischen
fragen volles und direkt das
initiativrecht des parlaments oder eben
auch schutz der grundwerte wenn man
gehen wenn wenn sie sozusagen jetzt die
option hätten ich möchte etwas mit auf
den tisch legen auf die agenda was
beraten werden muss noch sind wir nicht
so weit aber dann könnten sie aus ihrer
volkswirtschaftlichen perspektive jetzt
noch mal ein wirklich hier kann es
spreche also die abschaffung des
einstimmigkeitsprinzips
bedarf der einstimmigkeit insofern ist
es schon mal glaube ich da können wir da
können wir lange drüber reden das wird
so schnell nicht passieren konvente sind
immer sind immer was ganz tolles vor
allem wenn am ende mehr dabei rumkommt
als spesen
ich glaube was ganz vordringliches ist
die wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
europäischen union das ist das was jetzt
zählt südostasien läuft uns davon wir
haben geringe
produktivitätsfortschritte wir haben
eine inflation die auch daran liegt dass
die geldmenge zwar erhöht wurde aber die
produktion nicht das sind das die das
sind die punkte die auf dem tisch liegen
und da können wir noch so viele konvente
machen die probleme werden wir dadurch
nicht lösen
also haben wir andere dinge auf der
agenda an dem wir uns zu wenden können
jetzt schauen die
politikwissenschaftlerin charlene säle
angel
da ist gerade was das institutionelle
angehen und sie hat ja auch gesagt bevor
wir uns erweitern wollen müssen wir an
die reform denken die was sie noch nicht
ganz klar gesagt hat in irgend welcher
reihenfolge das wieder ablaufen soll da
haben wir ja schon lehrgeld alle
bezahlen müssen aber was wäre sozusagen
ihr wunsch an so ein konvent naja in
einer idealen welt
würde ich mir natürlich wünschen dass
wir uns institutionell neu aufstellen
bevor es die nächste erweiterungsrunde
gibt aber ich finde es auch vermessen
die erweiterung so lange aufzuschieben
bis wir das geschafft haben weil ich
glaube beides sozusagen so eng
miteinander zu verkoppeln ist dann auch
den weiteren kandidaten die schon sehr
lange und sehr viele reformen
durchgeführt haben dann auch nicht fair
gegenüber aber nichtsdestotrotz ich
glaube es ist ganz zentral dass wir
einen solchen konvent brauchen aus
zweierlei gründen grund eins ist das wie
eine reihe von themen auf dem tisch
haben wo wir unmittelbar reformbedürftig
sind das sind nicht so sehr die
unmittelbaren wirtschaftspolitischen
themen da gebe ich ihnen recht da wird
ein konvent nichts bringen aber die
thema themen rechtsstaatlichkeit auch
gesundheitspolitik wo uns die letzten
zwei jahre gezeigt hat dass da auch
einiges im argen ist und da sind wir in
einer situation wo wir ein paket deal
brauchen und ein solcher pakete
muss man in einem großen kreis schaffen
und muss man auch die möglichkeit geben
dass themen verknüpft werden können dass
man jeder dann etwas gewinnen kann jeder
etwas bekommt was er oder sie mit nach
hause nehmen kann und dafür muss man
verschiedene themen verbinden und da ist
ein konvent letzter satz das richtige
instrument weiter alle mit am tisch
sitzen das ist wieder ein bisschen basar
mal sieht was gerade mit nach hause
nehmen das hatte ich dann teppich ein
bisschen schon herborn sie haben dieser
tage
süffisant und elegant wie sie das häufig
tun in ihrem blog geschrieben lost in
europe über personal entscheidungen die
getroffen werden und über hinterzimmer
gerade jetzt aktuell im europäischen
parlament vielleicht wäre ihr wunsch
dann an so ein konvent das durch europa
etwas mehr transparenz gibt in den
institutionen
absolut natürlich wenn also der
generaldirektor des europaparlamentes
dieser posten neu besetzt wird dann kann
das nicht im hinterzimmer passieren dann
kann das nicht nach zehn minuten
anhörung im kleinsten kreis passieren
nach einem postengeschacher innerhalb
der fraktion zwischen den fraktionen und
soße slider gelaufen sondern dann muss
natürlich ein ordentliches
bewerbungsverfahren mit einer echten
konkurrenz laufen
aber leider werden die posten nicht nur
im parlament auch in der kommission dem
rat weiter so vergeben letzten endes
zählt der konvent natürlich schon auf
die europawahl und es ist ja auch eine
wichtige forderung des konvents dass das
spitzenkandidaten verfahren wieder
eingeführt reformiert und wieder
eingeführt wird dass die bürger eine
echte wahl haben und dass diese war dann
auch den staats und regierungschefs
respektiert wird insofern ist das unfair
sondern ein wink mit dem zaunpfahl an
das europaparlament an die bürger ich
denke an euch ich habe eure wünsche und
forderungen nicht vergessen ich habe
auch nicht vergessen dass es beim
letzten mal nicht so toll gelaufen ist
aber ein dollar an nach und die grosse
frage ist ob ein content in zeiten des
krieges wirklich realistisch ist die
mehrheit der eu-staaten ab von
abgewunken und auch deutschland hat
bedenken geäußert und gesagt viele
reformen werden wohl auch ohne konvent
möglich sein das heißt ich halte das
letzten endes auch wieder symbolpolitik
danke herr börse frau priesmeier bleibt
jetzt ich hatte ja vorher gesagt wir
machen das elegant und
mit ruhe jetzt machen was ein bisschen
dynamischer aber 40 sekunden für ein
konvent grundrechte schutz der
grundrechte wertefrage das hatten sie
von lange texte das ist auf jeden fall
auf natürlich dieses thema auswirkungen
der digitalisierung auf unser leben es
ist eine enorme geschichte also ein
neues thema der st informationen auch
natürlich medienfreiheit und bedeutung
der propaganda in diesem zusammenhang
das sind themen mit dem wir uns
beschäftigen werden weil wir hier
kommt versuchen all das zu kommunizieren
die generation tik tok
aufmerksamkeitsspanne von 30 sekunden
maximal
glück das ist
wir müssen uns ist auch klar sein dass
all das worüber wir diskutieren
natürlich wir wir erschaffen die welt
oder die union für die zukünftige
generationen dafür die entscheider von
morgen und sie brauchen einfach mal eine
ganz andere herangehensweise also
weniger show weniger bürgerforen aus
denen nichts wird mehr wirklich
bürgernähe das ist sehr wichtig aber
auch mehr regionales europa auch dieses
verständnis dass europa geschieht lokal
und vor ort und das muss auch
angesprochen werden
herzlichen dank meine damen meine herren
auch die zuschaltung aus brüssel darf
mich sehr bedanken für ihre engagierte
für den mehrwert den wir hatten in
dieser debatte und ich danke auch ihnen
dass sie ihre zeit mit uns geteilt haben
meine damen und herren am donnerstag in
der phoenix runde ohne die green was
wird aus dem vereinigten königreich das
fragen wir dann gute informationen als
phönix und
bei uns hier gleich phoenix der tag mit
maja weber sehr empfohlen
[Musik]